the leftists pinkos hippies and freaks
who make up the Democrat electoral
coalition met last week and over the
weekend at the Netroots nation
conference to establish their strategy
for 2020 Cory Booker Kamala Harris
Lyle waffle is Warren comrade de Blasio
all made their pitch to that wretched
hive of scum and villainy we have got
the highlights spoiler alert they hate
you and want to control your lives then
Kamala Harris is perverse view of her
own country on this is America and we
electrocute a criminal on this day in
history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael nul show
[Music]
a lot to get to a lot to get to today so
we have all the network Netroots clips
and man they're good they're the
Democrats are really outdoing themselves
lately so all of this should make 2020
very exciting very entertaining and pave
the way for president Trump's reelection
and we'll get to that before we get to
that let's make a little money honey
because we're not socialists yet we're
capitalist still and we still need to
make some money so let's talk about
honey
as it were let's talk about actual honey
chances are you've heard of it you've
probably heard of it cuz I've told you
about it honey is the free shopping tool
that finds the best promo codes wherever
you shop online and if it sounds too
good to be true and this is the one time
that it isn't too good to be true this
is just a fabulous product it's totally
free the question is how much money can
honey really save me turns out honey has
already saved people over eight hundred
million dollars it's almost enough to
pay for like five minutes of Alexandria
ocasion Cortez's social programs but
it's a lot of money that's a lot of
money I have been using it for years and
years and years you might also think
honey doesn't work at the sites I shop
at truth is honey works on over 30,000
websites Amazon eBay Walmart Newegg
j.crew and more it's always free and it
just saves you money it gets a small
commission from these sites where it
saves you money so it can save you money
I've been using it for years and years
and years I can't even tell you the last
time I bought a product with it because
I buy all of my products using honey it
just automatically finds you the best
deals it is free money put it in your
browser now no reason not to try it it
is free installs in just two clicks go
to join honey calm / go FFA CEO of EF EF
e join honey calm / go FFA see a VF EF e
+ + save a lot of money like I have for
years ok we got to get to knit routes so
if you're not familiar with it I
actually wasn't familiar with the name I
remember the event but the Netroots
nation conference started in 2006
if that number sounds familiar to you
it's because that was the year that the
Democrats made their huge lurch to the
left they they decided they were going
to double down they were gonna they were
gonna be the Democrat base of the
Democrat Party and they're gonna move
far left and it actually did help them
in the short run it did help
when some seats so they're doubling down
that they're gonna be trying to make
that same move again Netroots began as
the agenda-setting
moment for the left and for the democrat
party it begins you know that website
daily coast I don't think it's that big
anymore but it used to be very big even
five six years ago the daily Coast was
very far left site by Marco small eats
us it was his blog and so anyway he and
a bunch of other lefty angry bloggers
got together and started the this first
was a conference for DailyKos then it
became net roots net roots is where
you've seen some great moments in that
networks before even if you don't know
it do you remember that moment last year
where Bernie Sanders was on stage
talking about socialism and then he got
out lefted because black lives matter
came on stage and took his microphone
and he said well you can stay there you
can you that's fine that's okay and it
zoomed in on him with their like with
the Curb Your Enthusiasm music you know
that betta and they stole his microphone
they did the same thing to Martin
O'Malley actually nobody even remembers
Martin O'Malley
he was the generic bland
guitar playing guy who never had a
chance at winning the Democrat
nomination in 2016 so Martin O'Malley
was giving a speech at Netroots and
blacklivesmatter did the same thing to
him they took his microphone you know it
always is fun because it's really
they're crazies you know it's you really
can't compare the crazies on the right
and the left
everybody's got our crazies but like the
the crazies on the right you with a few
exceptions the crazies on the right just
like really like the Constitution those
are that's those are our most eccentric
people with again with a few exceptions
but the the kind of majority of the
eccentric fringy people on the right
they're just like yeah I really like
freedom I know that you like freedom I
really like freedom the ones on the left
are screaming I mean they're like
shrieking shutting people down coming
onstage threatening people that's what
you get at Netroots so at Netroots we
got we got everyone to try through here
all of the 2020 presidential contenders
walk through we got cory booker Kamala
Harris comrade de Blasio Liz Warren a
bunch of other people alexandria Ocasio
Cortez came out and of course she did
you know she's the new darling
the Democrats they try to say by the way
when we knock ok Jie Cortez for not
knowing anything and for being proudly
ignorant she they say well she's just
she's just a candidate somewhere in
Queens she's not the head of the party
they're making her the head of the party
they are turning her into a superstore
that's why she's fair game for us all to
to attack so they're doubling down they
think it's 2006 they're going to run in
2018 and in 2020 is though it's 2006
hard left they think they're going to
double down on their base that's going
to motivate them to go out to the polls
I hope they do this I know they don't
watch my show so I'm not worried about
letting the cat out of the bag the
secret is that 2018 is not 2006 it is so
not 2006 2006 you know there was a lot
of anger over the Iraq war that was
really the motivating factor on the left
there was a lot of distaste for George
Bush but mostly for that reason in 2018
we have peace abroad we've got a booming
economy you've got a terrific economy
coming out you know how did the left
turn their 2006 victory into a 2008
victory it's because there was this
devastated devastating economic crash
now we don't have that we have record
high employment record low unemployment
we've got a great account economy has
never done better
the IMF credits president Trump's
policies for that everybody's gotten a
tax break virtually everybody some
wealthy people in blue states haven't
quite gotten a tax break but everyone
else everyone who would vote for
Republicans everyone that the Democrats
want to put in their so-called coalition
of the ascendant has done very well in
this economy and um you know what they
do there their entire strategy is to
divide people along racial lines along
ever more precise racial gender lines
the numbers don't look good in that
direction president Trump's support
among black voters is now at 29% now
that doesn't sound very high that sounds
pretty low it should it should be higher
hopefully it will be higher by the end
of this term and certainly by the end of
the second term and third term fourth
room you know it'll keep it'll keep
increasing but his support just a year
ago was at 15% that support has
basically doubled in one year among
black voters and the Democrats are
running scared they're terrified by this
so they're trying to they're trying to
demagogue on race issues on class
shoes on all of this have it having set
up all of that the having set up what
seems to be the Democrats unsuccessful
set up for 2018 let's delve in to the
craziness and enjoy their their a
spectacular failure take it away in Iowa
according to trump the problem is other
working people people who are black or
brown people who were born somewhere
else
people who don't worship the same dress
the same or talk the same as Trump and
his buddies before getting into all of
that when she says don't worship the
same does she mean they're not lapsed
Presbyterians what do you mean by
doesn't worship the same you know
they're what they're trying to do is run
up against this stereotypical religious
right hard ideological conservative and
they keep failing at that because Donald
Trump isn't those things he regularly
misspeaks when he's trying to discuss
Christianity he's not fluent in the
language of Christianity because he's
not a figure of the Religious Right
someone asked him if he'd asked God for
forgiveness he said I try not to make
any mistakes that's why I don't have to
ask for forgiveness
then she says you know he's trying to
divide working people against this and
that and this is that he represents
those people he represents the people
that Elizabeth Warren wants to represent
but she can't she is a liar or first of
all she lied I we make jokes about this
because she's liya
she's chief spreading bull and but she
this is really offensive to a lot of
people she is the whitest woman that has
ever walked the earth and she lied about
being a racial minority to get
preferential treatment in employment
she won if regardless because those
policies are on the books she could have
taken a job away from an actual Native
American and she lied she she's just a
fraud through and through but also she's
this effete Harvard professor this true
elitist
who looks like one and speaks like one
to use her identity politics and Donald
Trump doesn't he doesn't talk like one
of those people he doesn't talk like any
elitist he talks to people in the way
that people talk on the street he talks
to people like the way that New Yorkers
talk that is much more compelling
much more attractive I'll let Liz Warren
keep going and it comes in all sorts of
flavors racism sexism homophobia
xenophobia it comes in all sorts of
forms nasty personal attacks trolling on
Twitter winking at white supremacists
and it all adds up to the same thing the
politics of division politics that tries
to pit black working people against
white working people so they won't band
together politics of division that tells
Americans to distrust each other to fear
each other to hate each other
you see the politics of division by
Donald Trump they they keep white
working people in black working people
apart so they don't join up and kill the
rich whitey that's saying it son I don't
does she hear herself when she's talking
the left is always projecting and here
more than ever
she's she's talking about dividing
people along all of these lines and all
of the language that she uses to divide
to describe this divides people along
precisely those lines
she is dividing people against along
lines of race not the Republicans not
taunting Trump not Mike Pence not Paul
Ryan no they're not she is she's
dividing people along lines of wealth
and class not Donald Trump not the
Republican Party she's dividing people
along all of these lines the way that
they rattle off that phrase racist
sexist xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic phobic phobic laia watha
phobic i malaya wathah phobic I'd I
certainly would fear her if she were in
the White House the way they rattle it
off like they've been practicing it in
their sleep like they say it in their
sleep they're talking about the
boogeyman that doesn't exist we have the
lowest amount of overt racism in the
history of the United States possibly in
history of the world anywhere else in
the world
I don't know if you've traveled much but
the rest of the world is not as
enlightened on on racial matters and
ethnic matters and cultural matters
the United States's we're doing better
than anyone else in the history of the
world and but Liz warns they just repeat
this this boogeyman that they need to
the thing that they need to have and by
the way they forget even just the
question of this this kind of bigotry of
that kind of bigotry they are the ones
that are promoting anti black bigotry
vicious physically intimidating anti
black bigotry against a friend of mine
Candace Owens but we will get to that in
one second before we do that I've got to
talk about movement well you've probably
seen you've seen my watch that I wear
all the time I kid you not I get so mu
you know movement
MVM T movement watches those two college
dropouts they've been selling now 2
million watches in 160 plus countries
they have revolutionized fashion on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank if you were to buy a watch like
this in a department store and I have it
would be $300 for it could be $500
movement watches start at just 95 bucks
because they figured out by Semele
online they can cut out the middleman
and retail markup provide the best
possible price
classic designed quality construction
style minimalism I kid you not I get a
compliment on this watch almost every
day
I my bank teller complements me on it
the bartender complements me on it plate
when I go to a party people do all the
time it's there they've just figured out
style it's got this kind of retro vibe
but it's very modern it's a really
high-quality watch
I've had some watches where have to take
them out of my bedroom because they take
to lab look and they keep me up at night
this does not at all this is just a
really sleek high-quality timepiece this
one is the revolver collection it's my
favorite you need to go buy these
watches by the way so that they can send
me more freebies because I mean I I'm
buying these watches myself for friends
and family they're just really really
cool I can't even they won't give me
enough freebies to do it and they're
just they're just as far as the watches
go on the market right now you can't not
beat it get 15% off today and don't say
I never did nothing for you free
shipping and free returns go-to movement
con /qf fa m VMT dot-com / coffe fa ce
o-- v fe fe c y movement keeps growing
check out their expanding collection go
to em VMT com / cough fac of e fe fe
join the movement and and get get this
cool revolver watch this is their cool
they got
other cool collections that have just
come out too but this is like it's like
my favourite watch okay
we've got to get back to Liz Warren so
you know they're they're talking about
they're all of that racial bigotry that
the right is spewing against the the
left against black people they're anti
black bigots aren't they
let's cut to a video of my friend
Candace Owens walking around with
Charley Kirk of TP USA
you've got the anti Fateh the
anti-fascists and to translate that for
you anti fascist in left-wing language
means fascist so you've got these people
just screaming in her face for
supporting Republican politicians here
they are
[Applause]
[Applause]
did you did you hear that
like shrieking from hell just like these
demons these just screaming in her face
for those of you who couldn't see the
video they're yelling F white supremacy
at Candace Owens a black woman they are
all white people they're all white women
white women with like crazy blue hair
and probably deep-seated emotional
problems stemming from their families I
don't know they're alive they got a lot
of issues going on clearly if you get up
to someone's face and starts screaming
at them in public you've got some issues
but it's all these white girls going up
with loud whistles with megaphones right
into Candace's ears and shrieking F
white supremacy that that is white
supremacy that they are they are the
white supremacists they are the white
people who are drowning out physically
intimidating Candace Owens because of
her beliefs for thinking what she wants
to think because you're not supposed to
they say no if you're black you're not
allowed to you're not allowed to think
that listen to us we're white women
we're allowed to tell you black woman
what to think that's what they're saying
I mean it is it is really it's easy to
make fun of it and Candace has thick
skin she's a tough girl and she can
handle herself very well obviously but
this is really deeply offensive and
horrifying these white girls shrieking
in her face how dare you how dare you
hold a position that I don't give you
permission to hold that's what they're
saying to Candace Owens really crazy
that's the left though that is what
they're doing to her the left is always
projecting onto other people their own
biases their own sins I'm saying F white
supremacy you're the white supremacist
you're the what's your the one who's
telling people how they have to think
how they have to behave and if they
don't get in line you're gonna
physically intimidate them
you're gonna scream in their face for
them blow out their eardrum so I don't
want to I don't want to let Liz Warren
totally get away though I mean those
were the highlights from her speech I
don't want to let her totally get away
though there was another another woman
who comes up to the podium and I think
this was a dig at Liz Warren you judge
for yourself
please welcome to the great state of New
Mexico
Deb Harland
[Applause]
to learn every station my name is Deb
Holland I'm the Democratic nominee for
New Mexico's first congressional
district if elected if elected I will be
the first Native American woman in
Congress did you catch that didn't catch
that you sure you're not the second Deb
you sure you think that lady was whiter
than Casper the ghost over there you
don't think she's the first Native
American in Congress you don't know
maybe not now I guess it would be Deb so
I really like that I think it is a dig
it Liz Warren because it is offensive to
people who who you know don't lie about
where they come from but this is the
kind of thing right this is what you get
at the Netroots conference this is what
the Democrats are setting up for 20/20
their platform is going to be all
identity all identity politics not
thoughts not ideas not even public
policy all identity listen to me because
I'm a Native American woman listen to me
in the case of Liz Warren because I'm a
fake Native American woman listen to me
because I'm a Black Muslim lesbian
Martian from Venus I don't know how I
was that pod I don't know how that's
possible and illegal alien you might say
the another serious contender showed up
Kamala Harris Komal Harris from my own
state of California what was most
interesting about her speech though
because she touched on all the same
points but she played it safe and I'm I
wonder what that shows here is Kamala
Harris spouting inane platitudes as I
look around this room I see the best of
what America is really about and I see
the best of what America can be
unburdened by what we have been and I
see in this room and all that is
represented in this room the power of
the people and these past 18 months have
demonstrated that the people in power
are no match for the power of the people
[Applause]
Wow how brave where did when did you
write that just utter platitudes and I
am here to tell you that the sky is blue
not red it's not red it's blue the sky I
am here B I am so proud to be here
because this Sun is bright not dark it's
not dark it's it's bright they go oh do
i clap i don't know she said it in such
an emphatic way there's a character a
congresswoman character on 30 rock i
don't know if you've seen this i forgot
her name and she kind of like maybe the
fifth season or something and she comes
in and she just starts talking and
saying things that are just either inane
platitudes or nonsense but because she
says them in fatica ly everyone gives
her a standing ovation that was Kamala
Harris at this in that roots conference
and a part of that is she's considered a
favor going into this election we don't
really know anything about her she's
relatively new to the Senate she doesn't
have much of a record we know she's a
lefty but a lot of the commentary about
her has focused on all of these aspects
of identity politics she herself has
totally embraced identity politics she
has run on them she's I'm a black woman
that's why you've got to support me
that's why I'll be good and so I think
perhaps Kamala Harris thinks she's going
into 2020 with this great advantage the
Democrats are embracing identity
politics that is what they're running on
she has the most identity politics not
only black but a woman not only in a not
only woman but a from California I don't
know issue all of these you know not
only that but she's young and she's this
and that right she checks all of these
boxes and so she thinks all right I can
play it safe because this is mine right
now I'm in the lead right now and I
don't know given her electoral coalition
that very well might be the case she
clearly has an advantage over Cory
Booker because Cory Booker is a man made
Kamala Harris as a woman so she she
played it relatively safe but she still
got her hits in I mean she still had her
cred here is Gamla Harris going on let's
speak truth that if it wasn't clear
before Charlottesville it is clear now
racism is real in this country and we
need to deal with that
let's speak truth sexism is real in this
country let's deal with it let's speak
truth anti-semitism homophobia
transphobia are real in this country
let's deal with this so she had to get
those lines in you hate you heard Liz
Warren do it true they all have to go
and they say America's awful I'm it ads
racist sexist xenophobic Islamophobic I
love by the way that they equate
Islamophobia with racism with with
hatred of people for their skin your
skin is something you can't change
unless you're a pedophile like pop store
you can't change the color of your skin
unless you have a lot of money and a an
amusement park in your house in
California but your your views you can
change views are up for criticism
it's very mean to criticize someone for
the way they look for any any aspect of
the way they look it's just crude and
rude and not very civilized but to
criticize someone for holding bad ideas
is perfectly legitimate in fact that's
what we are called to do in society and
civil society in a civilization where we
are where we discuss things and where we
have a democratic republic that's what
we're called to do religion is just a
bag of ideas it's just a bunch of ideas
and to equate those two is a real
sleight of hand the left always does
this but she's doing it too
so she gets all of her hits him okay she
she comes out of this thing looking fine
she doesn't look too wacky she didn't
you know she didn't Ocasio Cortes
herself she makes some bizarre gaffers
like crazy gesticulations and spouting
things that just like orders of
magnitude from being from being true the
biggest disappoint was Cory Booker the
biggest disappointment probably to
himself certainly to Democrats is Cory
Booker here is Cory giving given at his
level best we say an oath that we are a
nation of liberty and justice for all
but that's just words it's a civic faith
but I'm one of these people that says
before you tell me about your religion
first show it to me and how you treat
other people
well how are we living our civic gospel
how are we living our civic gospel that
demands for us to reject the normalcy of
injustice the normalcy of apathy the
normalcy of indifference and rise to the
higher ground of activism of engagement
of love and that's the last person I
want to end with his name is Hasan
Washington I'm a big believer that if
America this country hasn't broken your
heart then you don't love her enough
because there's things that are savagely
wrong in this country there's a normalcy
of injustice that we've accepted and I
tell you Newark has gifted me a wisdom
that can only come from wounds a sense
of purpose that can only come from
shared pain it's a city that at times
where my heart has been broken but I've
learned that the heart is this
interesting organ that could it's the
only one that really works even if it's
gotten broken I get that man whatever
the opposite of an Oscar is get that for
Cory I've said in on a lot of auditions
over time New York LA College you know
even before that and I don't know that I
have and I've seen a lot of bad
performances I've seen a lot of truly
horrific plays movies I have never seen
anything as unconvincing as Cory Booker
trying to be emotional I have never seen
it it just doesn't I'm not trying to be
mean to Cory Booker it just doesn't pass
the smell test it doesn't look real I
don't think anybody in that room thought
that he was genuine it's so disingenuous
too it's so he's not he's just not good
at performing emotion look Cory Booker
is a very smart guy he is very
intelligent he has a lot to offer his
party and I don't know about it if he's
got a lot over the country but he's got
a lot to offer his party at least but
he's playing wrong you can't give a
little a little more advice from you
know Stanislavski and Sanford Meisner
and you know great great two acting
directors and
and coaches you you can't push you don't
want to push against what is coming sort
of naturally too and what comes
organically Cory is all pushing right
now because he's not he's this guy from
New Jersey who was cozy with Wall Street
and has zillionaire donors and you know
it defended Mitt Romney in 2012 that's
who Cory Booker actually is he's now
running left of Lenin because he thinks
that that's gonna work he thinks that's
going to get him the nomination it's not
because you have to be authentic the
lesson of 2016 should have been that you
have to be authentic when you're not
authentic you get blown off the stage by
somebody who is really really sad he is
savagely wrong
it's savagely tears of rage said no also
just a usage note please he said that
Newark gifted him with something that's
not a word the verb to gift is not I
know it's been in use it has been in use
at various times for three or four
hundred years two gifts i gifted this to
you it's not proper there's a wonderful
word which is a give I give you this and
now you have a gift from me I've got a
gift because I gave it to you I'll give
it to you gifted I gifted this damn it's
just like nails on a chalkboard Corey
come on you went to Yale Law School
learn how to use language better
let's get those tears out of here okay
so the main the main takeaway this is
all the Democrats are running very far
left I don't want to harp on this too
much but they all of the candidates here
advocated Medicare for all open borders
and abolishing law enforcement agencies
every single one of them a Medicare for
all
I didn't think this was gonna work for
them I saw this percolating in the
fringes a couple of years ago few years
ago now they say Medicare for all and
that to me seems like such a sad sales
pitch when I think of Medicare I think
of old people who can't take care of
themselves who are at the mercy of the
government who are the mercy of the
state who are just frail and weak and
have no control over their own destinies
why would we all want that why would we
a do you should you too can be like an
85 year old I want to be like an 85 year
old I'll be like one when I'm 85 I don't
want to be like one now when I'm 28
still they've all embraced it they've
all embraced socialist health care all
the rest these are not popular issues
they're not popular you saw what
happened with Obama
it destroyed the Obama presidency
because he pushed that through people
hated that policy they hate open borders
the majority of Democrats a despised
open borders and they don't want to
prioritize any immigration legislation
including any amnesty legislation
including for the dreamers the majority
of Democrats don't want legislation
legalizing even dreamers that is a crazy
statistic of abolishing law enforcement
who wants that nobody wants that so okay
that's fine keep it up do it please I
hope this is your platform give it to me
all of these candidates by the way are
deeply flawed in a way that Trump is not
all of these candidates are far left and
they're running as ideologue far left
ideologues Trump never did that Trump
never did that they've tried to make him
into that on the left but he isn't that
he's totally heterodox he's not
ideological at all he actually boasted
about that in the campaign he said I
like this I don't like this I'm gonna do
this I'm not a religious conservative on
this I do he just he's his own character
he's authentic and there's a moderation
that comes out of that the people are
more comfortable there this is why
people are more comfortable with Donald
Trump than Mike Pence you would think
people would be more comfortable with
Mike Pence stable steady good
conservative politician but he believes
too many things they say oh he really
takes this belief seriously Trump I feel
like we can negotiate with him these
candidates are they're running into a
brick wall right now but keep it up I
hope I hope they do do I have to say
goodbye now I'll give one more bit in
then we'll say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube
so the the main takeaway from Netroots
is the left doesn't like you as you were
all vicious bigots and the left needs to
control every aspect of your lives your
healthcare your they're gonna take away
your ability to decide who comes in and
out of the country they're gonna take
away your money so that they can pay for
all of their crazy social programs they
really don't like you
Angela rise CNN commentator typify this
did this very well on Fredo Cuomo's show
the other day well well he just sat
there he just just take a listen to this
essentially not have any borders let's
be very clear
you have any illegal immigration in your
family childlike I don't know what
you're talking about you've never once
asked me if I'm for open borders you've
never once asked me that's really you
don't want it clearly fancy not clearly
in you to repeat clearly you don't want
it in course are clear you don't want to
enforce the the border laws because
that's what I said you know what I don't
want what I don't want to come on man
you guys know that this policy is asked
backwards
plain and simple you guys know this
policy is inhumane
plain and simple like if you just take
yourselves out of it for just a moment
take off the lenses of bigotry for just
a moment and imagine so now now we're
good now we're getting into the
name-calling yes we are I'm calling this
over there that you know with grave in
amidst all of this too you probably if
you were listening you wouldn't be able
to tell Chris Cuomo is there the Fredo
of the Cuomo family is sitting there
just just like this just just strut
wide-eyed just sitting there silent
staring like a Mook just just doing
nothing and he gets paid I might have
gotten paid a little bit to not write a
book but this guy gets paid a lot more
money to not host a TV show they're
letting her accuse his other guests of
being a bigot of being a racist out of
nowhere they made no they make she made
no argument whatsoever right she didn't
demonstrate anything through logic she
just said you're a bigot you're
prejudiced man why where you have bad
intentions I hate your guts and you're
terrible for the country really awful
stuff I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube but we'll explain
this like profound racism on the left as
it comes up through Sarah giong in the
New York Times and Candace Owens plus
we've got we've got to electrocute some
people in chairs on this day in history
we've got to show Kamala Harris and her
racist view of America on this isn't a
lot to come come back to so let's hurry
up and do it go to daily wire.com please
if you already there thank you very much
you help keep the lights on you keep
khofifah in my cup
if you're not go it's ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
you get the under Clavin show you get
the Ben Shapiro show you test questions
in the mailbag get to ask questions in
the conversation I think I'm up next
none of that matters because you get the
Cory Booker vessel you
get the leftist ears tumblr the leftist
tears of Rage tears of Rage because if
you don't have this tumblr you're gonna
think that something is savagely wrong
while you're drowning and left us tears
go to daily wire.com we'll be right back
savagely wrong
that's just savagely wrong to make fun
of cory booker you remember Sarah Jong
Sarah Jong is that tech reporter who
sent out all of these tweets about how
much she hates white people especially
white men and wants them to be
eradicated from the earth she actually
said that she said I I'm so happy that
white people aren't breeding so that
they'll go extinct she said we need to
cancel white people she said why people
shouldn't speak they should be censored
she just doesn't like them I'd say they
were jokes but they don't they were just
bursts of all they didn't have a punch
line and it just seems to me that the
over the years she's kept this up and
clearly just hates white people so they
pointed this out to the New York Times
New York Times stands by or on the
editorial board now a video has surfaced
at Sarah John from Harvard Law School
where she attended college or where she
attended law school here she is
everything is implicitly organized
around how men see the world and and not
just meant how white men see the world
and this is this is a problem this is
why so many things suck that's why white
men that's why so many things suck to
quote Sarah Jong New York Times
editorial board all the news that's fit
to print
I think the grey lady they cray it was a
good thing the great lady's not a white
lady otherwise Sarah John would unleash
some venom against her - this is the
left wing view of the world at this
point which is that a white man or the
or the cause of every problem in the
world and everyone needs to band
together through intersectionality to
take them down and to undo the
patriarchy and all of the other terms
they use for social hierarchies now any
reasonable person listening to this
would say wow she's a vile racist she's
at least saying vile racist things but
the left answers and says no no that's
not racist cuz she's not white you can
only be racist if you're white because
it's about power and only white people
have power nobody else has power voxcom
Zach Beauchamp writing for vox.com which
is whenever I want to learn whenever I
want to know less than I currently know
I go to voxcom
and then it just sucks knowledge out of
me Vox doc um he wrote 21 whoo
even passingly familiar with the way the
social justice left talks this is just
clearly untrue white people is a
shorthand in these communities one
that's used to capture the way that many
whites still act including us are racist
ways it's typically satirical or
hyperbolic to emphasize how white people
continue to benefit from their skin
color it were to point out ways in which
a power structure that favors white
people continues to exist what she what
he's saying is yeah the left uses white
do they hate white people that's right
they don't like white people and what
makes it different he writes what makes
it different from actual racism is yes
the underlying power structure in
American society it's okay to say
vicious things about whites because the
whites have all the power
but let's analyze that is that true
Sarah Jong is Asian Asian Americans have
higher average household income than
whites they have a higher average
household income than any other group
Asian Americans disproportionately are
accepted to top universities in the
country such as Harvard Law School such
as the place from which Sarah Jang was
making that statement by objective
measures Asians have much more power and
privilege in the United States now I I
reject the these racial categories per
se because I don't think they tell you
them they do tell you some things
they're sort of interesting
demographically and from matters of
electoral politics but they they don't
tell you very much about power they
don't tell you very much about politics
because they don't tell you about ideas
they don't tell you about laws there are
no there's no diss your racism in the
United States right there's no
structural racism saying okay only Asian
people can do this only white people can
do this absolutely not there I suppose
there is one law which is affirmative
action that says certain people get a
benefit in university admission and
other people do not but the the point
she's trying to make that whites have
all the power in America clearly isn't
true she's a living example of it she's
on the Editorial Board of the New York
Times it's a powerful position there
used to be at least I don't know if it
still is and the left is excusing this
Washington Post excused her vile remarks
and said is it okay to make fun of white
people online make fun of in left in
Washington Post language by the way
means call for the eradication of their
excusing it they they don't like the
country they don't like the history of
the country they all
talk about this they say we are gonna
move forward not be burdened by our past
you know this is this is the symbol of
their of their regulatory efforts in
2018 and 2020 is the plastic straws
that's the symbol the plastic straws
they need they are so riled up about how
awful this country's that they are gonna
go in and regulate everybody's life that
it's the plastic straws actually the guy
the the Santa Barbara councilman who
pushed for the plastic straw BAM who
pushed to make plastic straws illegal he
said quote unfortunately common sense is
just not common we have to regulate
every aspect of people's lives every
aspect that's what he said he's the guy
behind the straw bed that's how they see
the country going into 2020 going into
the midterms more power to them that I
don't know that that's a winning message
we hate you we hate everyone in the
country we you're all vicious bigots and
we want to control your lives and we're
gonna focus on the least popular public
policies that a public polling shows us
that's what they are pushing for more
power to them I hope I hope they do it
keep going guys we've got to get to this
is America and this is America
variations on a theme a startling number
of Americans don't know anything about
America they don't know anything about
America Kamala Harris actually typifies
this she tweeted out quote we won't be
silent about race we won't be silent
about sexual orientation we won't be
silent about immigrant rights these are
the very issues that define our identity
as Americans they're not those are not
the issues that define our identity as
Americans as a matter of fact that's
what the Left pretends defines our
identity identity as Americans race
class sex that's where they pretend us
but it doesn't what defines our identity
as Americans is our dignity given by God
and the rights conferred by our Creator
rights to life liberty and property
which come from the natural law which
come from the natural law Giver
it comes from freedom baby fre edom it
comes from freedom and having the
responsibility to deal in freedom in to
govern ourselves that's what it comes
from it doesn't come from the color of
your skin but a lot of people think that
according to a new study from the
Freedom Forum Institute on just the
First Amendment just the First Amendment
40% of respondents couldn't name any
part of the First Amendment
they couldn't name any of the rights
outlined in the First Amendment and just
one out of 1000 respondents could name
all of the rights in the First Amendment
right to speech freedom freedom of
religion freedom of press freedom of
assembly and freedom to lobby freedom to
petition your government only one out of
a thousand could name all of those all
of those rights there are other studies
that come out that show that students
the there was one from ISI that showed
students at some universities knew less
about civics when they graduated them
when they went in they somehow learned
they unlearned civics and their time in
there a startling number of people a 90
percent of respondents to one national
survey couldn't identify the system of
checks and balances in the government a
huge percentage couldn't identify the
purpose of the Bill of Rights a huge
percentage something like 70% couldn't
identify the purpose of the Bill of
Rights this is really scary it's cuz we
have no civics education in the country
at any level it's been replaced by
ideological studies like you now in high
schools you'll read Howard Zinn there
are no civics classes but you'll read a
people's history of the United States X
[ __ ] leftist propaganda
there's no civics education and freedom
is only one generation away from
extinction as Ronald Reagan said if you
don't understand your government the
systems of your government then you're
going to lose them people don't even
know about the Bill of Rights but they
certainly don't know about the system
that built our government you know any
tin-pot dictator can have a bill of
rights but we have a federal system of
checks and balances which the left is
willing to undermine they don't
understand the purpose of the country
and if you don't understand the purpose
of the country long enough you lose it
before we go I've got to get to this day
in history this day in history is a very
important one because in 1890 on this
day in history the first criminal was a
sentence Tudor was executed by the
electric chair this is a little grim but
you know people have been talking about
the death penalty a lot lately the
current Vicar of Christ on earth Pope
Francis has been talking about that so I
think it shed some light on this this
debate conservatives are asking now in
light of the Pope's comments
what can we support the death penalty
conservatives even debated this before
they say do we want to give the state
the power to kill people okay is it
right for the state to kill criminals is
that Catholics have debated this Pope
Benedict said I think 20 years ago that
Catholics could have a legitimate
difference of opinion on the death
penalty what do we think about it it's
being outlawed all over the country so
in 1890 at the Auburn prison in New York
William Kemmler was electrocuted for
murdering his lover with an axe he
murdered his lover with an axe he was
sentenced to death and he was
electrocuted
electrocution had been suggested 9 years
earlier by Albert Southwick there have
its Southwark or Southwick Albert
Southwick I'll just say that who was a
dentist and you know dentists are so
they're so sadistic and they clearly
like means of torturing people so anyway
he he proposed the electric chair
because he one time saw an elderly
drunkard a painlessly killed because he
touched an electrical generator up in
Buffalo that's how he saw it he said oh
this would be a good way to kill people
hanging was a little less humane with
people who were hanged when they hang
the criminals they would their necks
would break but they could hang there
for half an hour before they were
totally asphyxiated that's not good so
they said okay we're gonna zap these
guys full of electricity this would be
humane this is the better way this is
the this Society has advanced here
Kendler was strapped in they sent 700
volts of electricity to him for 17
seconds and the current failed so they
they only sort of braised him they
didn't really cook him they didn't fully
they just braised him and so he had I
mean he was charred all over people
could smell burnt clothing but he was
still alive and then a little bit later
they sent another charge over a thousand
volts they let it go for two minutes
until his head was smoking then they
realized he was gone this might sound a
little gruesome Southwick said the guy
who advocated the electric chair he said
we live in a higher civilization from
this day on and a lot of people looked
at it that way they said oh good we've
we just cooked that guy while he was
still alive and he was charred but not
dead we burned a hole right to his
spinal column and we had smoke coming
out of his head we live in a higher
civilization from this day on people can
confuse themselves on moral issues
particularly issues of life and death
particularly when they're people
George Westinghouse a contemporary who
was an innovator of the use of
electricity at that time he had a
different take on it he said quote they
would have done better with an axe and
they would have done better with an axe
he would have suffered less with an axe
they would have done better just simple
simple execution had served people well
for a long time one wonders if this is
not the case when it comes to the death
penalty it's very it seems so morally
clear not to use the death penalty to
people who have shallow thinking it
seems so morally clear that it's awful
you know the church the Catholic Church
despite this change recently taught for
2,000 years that the death penalty is
not intrinsically evil st. Agustin wrote
in defense of it st. Thomas Aquinas
wrote in defense of it st. Paul writes
in defense of it and there seems to be a
change now perhaps the better question
is to ask what changed why do we why do
we suddenly think that this thing is
intrinsically immoral that this thing is
evil
it I think it says a lot more about our
culture in our decadent culture and our
moral myopia that we can frequently have
and nobody can attest to that better
than the burnt crisp jars of William
Kemmler on this day in history in 1890
on that grisly gruesome disgusting final
note I got to say goodbye to you come
back tomorrow as that for a pitch come
back tomorrow
make sure you get your mailbag questions
in and tune in to another kingdom and
for season binge that baby because we're
about to release the second season me
and Andrew Clavin it's gonna be a lot of
fun tune in then in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy bori senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
hair and makeup is by Jeshua ov era the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018